ici quand moi je suis très très
satisfait parce que d'une part on garde
de trois cantons là où mes adjoints mes
anciens adjoints et qui étaient sortants
gardent leur canton avec des souvent de
très bons scores et puis on fait 49,7 %
des suffrages à Caen pour la gauche un
an après la défaite des municipales
c'est tout à fait encourageant pour
l'avenir et puis enfin sur les deux
cantons qu'on ne gagne pas et bien on a
des petits jeunes des la le
renouvellement ici sur le camp 1 sur le
camp de comme sur le canton de
Ouistreham qui ont fait de très belles
campagnes qui sont qui ont montré une
très grande maturité politique c'est la
préparation de l'avenir donc tout ça est
plutôt satisfaisant dans un paysage qui
est morose mais alors dans ce contexte
de vague bleue comment est-ce qu'on
explique que la gauche cannelle résiste
un an seulement après la défaite au
municipale vous savez elle résiste pas
seulement dans le dans le Calvados pas
seulement dans l'agglomération canadien
regardez les résultat du Grand Sud-Ouest
c'est à dire les régions aquitaines
Midi-Pyrénées PACA on ne perd pas de
département là aucun on en gagne même la
Lozère bon c'est comme ça il y a l'ouest
de la France qui a beaucoup mieux que
l'est là où le Front National a beaucoup
avancé c'est dans les anciens
territoires industriels là où la crise
charbonnière la crise sidérurgie la
crise de la métallurgie on je dirais
provoquer des licenciements extrêmement
massifs et surtout un chômage de très
longue durée il y a une désespérance de
la population et bien sûr quand elle ne
trouve plus de réponse qui lui donne un
espoir dans les grands partis
républicains et bien la tendance à aller
vers des solutions irrationnelles qui ne
lui apporteront rien de mieux et au
contraire peuvent créer des dangers
importants mais c'est comme cela c'est
le genre humain si on se projette quand
même sur les échanges à venir sur les
régionales notamment 5 départements sont
aujourd'hui
à la droite pardon c'est une mauvaise
augure pour les régionales c'est pas
forcément de mauvaise augure
souvenez-vous de 2004 trois départements
en Basse-Normandie était à droite et on
a gagné la région à gauche et en 2010
Laurent Beauvais la regagné à gauche et
avec quel brio puisqu'il a fait le
quatrième score national avec trois
départements à droite